welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Darth initial
and with the rise of Skywalker and now
our worldwide it's time to take a closer
look at the big bad of the entire saga
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about Emperor Palpatine from
before the Phantom Menace all the way up
to the new film we'll be covering the
characters full biography his time as
Darth Sidious and how he returned from
the dead in the latest entry there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to see the rise of
Skywalker yet and don't want anything
potentially ruined then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Emperor Palpatine sheev
Palpatine was born on the planet of
Naboo around the Year 84 BBY she was the
child of a very influential family and
from an early age he was gifted with the
force this caught the eye of Darth
Plagueis a Sith Lord who took him under
his wing as an apprentice through
Plagueis she learned all the ins and
outs of the darkside from his master who
carried the lineage of Darth Bane
Plagueis showed him almost everything
including the ability to lead an eternal
life which we'll get into later in the
video eventually though she graduated to
the position of Darth Sidious and began
dabbling in politics using his dog
powers of manipulation in order to rise
up through the ranks upon the completion
of his training
Sidious betrayed his master and murdered
him in his sleep this was traditional
amongst the Sith and often their
apprentices would murder their masters
and assume their positions typically
this only of a two Sith in the galaxy
and Sidious began looking for an
apprentice himself whilst he gained a
prominent position in the Galactic
Senate firsthand he witnessed the
corruption within the Republic and
realized that he could easily manipulate
his way into power if he created a
divide his master plan was to overthrow
the Jedi who had been the guardians of
peace and justice for thousands of
generations and then supplant the
leadership with a new empire during this
time Sidious met a like-minded Jedi
named Dooku who too had become aware
that the corruption within the Republic
would eventually lead to its downfall
Sidious manipulated Dooku and slowly
turned him to the dark side
from inside the Senate they slowly built
up their puppet nute Gunray to the
position of Viceroy of the Trade
Federation alongside this Sidious also
travel to Dathomir
where he met a knight sister with
incredible power he promised to make her
his apprentice but at the last moment
betrayed her and instead kidnapped her
young son who would later become Darth
Maul once all of the pawns were in place
Palpatine moved to overthrow the Supreme
Chancellor and he ordered the Trade
Federation to create a blockade around
abû under the pretense that they were
protesting the Senate's taxation of
trade routes the Supreme Chancellor
dispatched two Jedi who yet if you've
seen the Phantom Menace that's qui-gon
jinn and his Padawan obi-wan Kenobi and
they tried to negotiate with the Trade
Federation
but Sidious ordered for them to be
executed the Trade Federation then
launched an invasion of the planet and
throughout the entire incursion Sidious
masterfully played both sides of the
battle appearing to the Trade Federation
as a Sith Lord and to Queen Amidala as
Senator Palpatine with the help of the
Jedi Amidala and her allies were able to
escape the planet during the invasion
and after a stop off on Tatooine they
met a young force sensitive boy named
Anakin from here they journey to chorus
and to try and ask the Senate for
intervention but yeah this kind of fell
on deaf ears the Senate were hopeless
just as Palpatine knew they would be and
he persuaded Amidala to move for a vote
of no-confidence in order to potentially
place a more powerful leader as the
Supreme Chancellor Palpatine predicted
the Senate agreed to remove the Supreme
Chancellor and Palpatine was elected in
his place he did try and convince
Amidala to stay in chorus aunt but you
wish to return to her world and Sidious
contacted the Trade Federation and sent
Maul with orders to kill the Queen upon
her arrival in addition to this upon
learning that she'd formed an alliance
with the Gungans of the planet
he ordered Trade Federation forces to
meet them in battle luckily the Queen's
assassination was stopped by the Jedi
and the group managed to defeat the
invading forces Palpatine learned that a
young boy named Anakin Skywalker was
instrumental in this and this caught his
attention as the freed slave had been
labeled as the chosen one and that would
bring balance to the force over the
following decade Palpatine built a
reputation as a brilliant chancellor
that was only interested in the good of
the galaxy
formed a friendship with Anakin grooming
him in a way and stating that he was the
most gifted Jedi that he had ever met
he realized that Anakin was happily
swayed by his emotions and through this
that he could be controlled he sowed the
seeds of frustration and Anakin all
while straining his new apprentice Count
Dooku Dooku left the order and began
operating under the name Darth Tyrannis
and the two Sith Lords carried out the
death of Jedi Master sifo-dyas and took
his commission to produce a clone army
on Kamino they implanted a secret order
known as order 66 in which all the
soldiers would turn on the Jedi and kill
em Dooku covered this up by erasing all
knowledge of the Commission from the
Jedi archives and he sent a near
impossible task for many mercenaries
Jango Fett managed to claim this and
using him as a template
he began duplicating the character in 30
BBY Palpatine travelled to jakku and
during this time he met a young boy
named Gally who served him for many
years it's also during this that I think
Palpatine may have also fathered a son
or he perhaps manipulated the
midi-chlorians in order to create life
which we'll get into further in the
video when discussing rey under Sidious
Dooku began traveling to planets
throughout the galaxy convincing them to
become independent from the Galactic
Republic he created the Confederacy of
Independent Systems and Dooku became the
leader of the group with the galaxy on
the brink of Civil War
and just too many planets for the Jedi
to control the Senate pushed to form a
grand army for the Republic
Amidala arrived on Quora son to vote on
the notion and after an assassination
attempt on her life Anakin was assigned
to protect her the two fell in love and
after the death of his mother and it can
wander towards the dark side lashing out
on his mother's killers in anger the
separatists were revealed to be secretly
creating a massive battle droid army
which Palpatine was of course behind and
after he was granted emergency powers by
ja ja Binks who yet ruined the galaxy he
was given the authority to rule over the
Senate without the need for a boat until
the conflict was over his first act was
to bring forth the clone army and thus
the clone wars began Anakin and Amidala
secretly married on Naboo and Palpatine
slowly started putting the pieces in
place to take him as an apprentice many
years passed with the war ravaging the
galaxy and it
during this a lot of heroes rose on each
side including General Grievous who was
commanded to capture Palpatine on
Coruscant
along with Dooku the two faked his
kidnap and fled to a separatist ship
during a large-scale battle Anakin and
obi-wan were called in to rescue him and
the former managed to kill Dooku after
he was instructed to by Palpatine
Palpatine also wished to leave I'll be
one behind but Anakin refused to and the
three managed to capture the ship and
land it Palpatine appointed Anakin to be
his representative on the Jedi Council
which they were very displeased with
they denied him the position of Jedi
Master and instead decided to use
Anakin's friendship with the character
to spy on him Anakin started having
visions of his wife's death and
Palpatine decided to use this to
manipulate him by discussing the
abilities of Darth Plagueis
and he can believe that together they
could save his wife and naturally the
two formed a bond
Anakin began to distrust the Jedi and
this was fueled by Palpatine who said
that they were plotting to take over the
Republic
Palpatine revealed that he was strong in
the force and Anakin concluded that he
was a Sith Lord mace Windu when a group
of Jedi confronted him
but Palpatine managed to kill most of
them but was bested by Windu Anakin
arrived there just in the nick of time
and he had a choice either help Windu
and doom his wife or save Palpatine and
potentially Padme Anakin chose the
latter and Palpatine commanded the clone
army to execute order 66 which wiped out
most of the Jedi and I can join their
murdering many of the Jedi forces under
the new identity Darth Vader Palpatine
addressed the Senate and stated that the
Jedi were planning to overthrow the
Republic the Republic was reclassified
as the Galactic Empire and yeah we all
know what happened from there the
remaining Jedi obi-wan Kenobi and Yoda
both went to confront Anakin and
Palpatine at separate locations
Palpatine bastard Yoda and he went into
exile and obi-wan beat his apprentice
watching as his body slowly fell into
the lava of Mustafar severely burning
him Palpatine arrived there and rescued
him but revealed that they'd been unable
to avert his wife's death and that she
had died in childbirth Palpatine saved
Vader through the use of machines and
together the Empire slowly began ruling
the galaxy with an iron fist it's also
during this time that Palpatine ordered
the remaining Jedi to be executed
and the Deathstar was constructed this
was a powerful super weapon with the
capability to destroy planets in one
blast now I believe that it was during
this time that Palpatine tried to mold
his son into a powerful Sith Lord but he
rejected this and fled finding a wife
and living life on jakku rebellion also
started to form that rejected the
empirical rule and they set up a base on
Yavin 4 through a team led by jin a so
they managed to steal the plans to the
Death Star and pass these on to rebel
forces Palpatine ordered Darth Vader to
intercept these but he failed
Princess Leia who unbeknownst to Vader
was his daughter managed to send the
plants Tatooine when they were
intercepted by Luke Skywalker her twin
brother who took them to Obi Wan yeah
it's a very small galaxy the events of a
new hope happened which saw the
destruction of the Death Star and
similars house Sidious had died of
Anakin after he destroyed the Trade
Federation flagship he set his sights on
Luke the Emperor ordered Vader to turn
him and the construction of a second
Death Star began he also started using
the force to extend his life and
continued his experimentation into
cloning in order to find the secret to
immortality
Luke handed himself in as an attempt to
redeem his father and here he came face
to face with Palpatine on the second
Death Star the battle for Vader's soul
began with Palpatine tempting Luke with
the dark side of the force
Palpatine used Luke's friends as bait
and revealed that he had led the rebels
to believe that the Death Star was not
operational and also that he was the one
who allowed the forces to reach Endor
this was to force Luke to strike him
down in anger and though he initially
resisted he did attempt to do this
though Vader intercepted it the to start
a lightsaber duel and on the planet of
Endor han and Leia led a team that
disabled the shield generator for the
battle station
Palpatine watched as Luke slowly used
anger to defeat his father but at the
last moment he calmed himself and threw
away his lightsaber he told Palpatine
that he would never turn to the dark
side and that he would always be a Jedi
like his father before him this angered
Palpatine and he tried to kill Luke
though Vader intervened throwing the
character down the Death Star reactor
shaft the rebels destroyed the Death
Star once more and Vader and Palpatine
died on it or so we thought in the rise
of Skywalker it was revealed that the
character
did not die and slowly he worked in the
shadows creating the first order in the
wake of the Empire's downfall
I've seen how Palpatine survived
theorized by many as cloning and this is
even given lip service in the movie
however I highly doubt that he would
clone himself with missing fingers in a
decrepit old body personally I believe
that he manipulated the midi-chlorians
as shown to him by Darth Plagueis and he
was able to use the Force to remain
alive during a vision in the force
awakens rey also hears his voice and we
discovered that he settled on the sith
world of EXA goal physically impaired
and pretty much all but dead except for
his consciousness he was sustained and
moved by machinery Sidious created
supreme leader Snoke and sent him forth
to rule over the first order and turn
Han and Leia's son Ben solo Sidious
managed to impersonate Ben's grandfather
Darth Vader and turn him to the dark
side Ben took up the mantle kylo Ren and
he eventually became besotted with
Palpatine's granddaughter Rey Palpatine
had sought after her for many years
sending out Syd loyalists to try and
capture her but these were all
unsuccessful Palpatine son hid her away
and they died protecting her location
a mysterious broadcast was sent out into
the galaxy by Palpatine threatening
revenge and kylo who had assumed the
position of supreme leader when
searching for the source of this scared
that his power would be stripped away
kylo eventually came across Palpatine
discovered that he was behind Snoke and
learned that he had amassed a huge
amount of Star Destroyers that Palpatine
had labeled the final order
Palpatine wanted to return the Empire to
its rightful position and he wished for
his granddaughter to join him by his
side Ren came face-to-face with Rey
several times revealing her lineage and
this led the two to battle on the second
Death Star's runes leia reached out to
him just before dying and this
distracted him to the point that rey was
able to stop him rey fled to act you and
after speaking with luke realized that
she had to confront her grandfather Rey
travelled to EXCI goal ascending her
coordinates to the resistance and came
across Palpatine surrounded by Savoia
lists Palpatine stated that all of the
Sith lived within him and that she had
to take his place this is an ancient
Sith ritual which would allow him to
transfer his spirit into her and
continue the legacy
of the sith he revealed that the
resistance forces had been led into a
trap and that the only way for Rey to
save them would be to join him in
controlling the Sith fleet and to stop
the annihilation however a redeem Ben
solo arrived and with Rey they fought
Palpatine realizing their force bond was
stronger than initially suspected he
drained our life force to restore
himself he flung Ben into a pit and
tried to destroy both the resistance
fleet and Rey using Force Lightning Rey
managed to deflect this similar to how
mace windu once did and calling on all
the power of the Jedi from the past she
killed him turning his own power against
him Palpatine was finally killed and
with its destruction the Sith and final
order were no more and that's everything
you need to know about Palpatine whether
the character will ever return remains
to be seen but that's all of the ins and
outs of his life from birth to death if
you enjoyed this video then please force
push that like button and if you want to
watch more Star Wars related stuff that
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the meaning behind the
ending of Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker we go over the movie's main
themes and the revelations so yeah it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server would you be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hope they
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of gioco which
was one of our favorite movies of the
air and all you have to do to be in with
a chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on Emperor
Palpatine in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the Celt be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised so best of luck to everyone he
takes part this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace